weiß ich nicht ich habe eigentlich noch
keinen gesehen hat das so macht wie dich
android was geht ab herzlich willkommen
bleibt ein video im ja ich hab das ja
letztens schon mal so angesprochen
wir sind gerade übrigens bei mir in
beiden smart ihr kennt das ja auch schon
so ein bisschen
es gibt ja bei mir so wirklich die tage
da sehe ich meine haare so voll gut aus
und es gibt tage da sehen wir total
scheiße aus an diesen tagen wo halt
meine haare im video gut auch sagen habt
ihr mich oder ein paar von euch kann man
immer gefragt wie macht es eigentlich
seine haare und da dachte ich so ich
hoffe ich habe heute wieder einen tag wo
die gut aussehen werden
wir können es immer versuchen ich habe
meine haare halt immer so in zwei
unterschiedlichen styles sag ich mal
deswegen würde ich sagen wir fangen mit
dem einen eigentlich einfach schnell an
und eigentlich ist das auch nichts
besonderes sondern einfach nur okay doch
ein trick hab ich der ist killer der
trick kann auch sein dass er nicht so
also dass jeder von euch kennt aber weiß
ich nicht ich habe eigentlich noch
keinen gesehen hat das format fähig als
ich würde sagen will aber gar nicht
lange ach ja sorry noch dass es hier so
hart aber wir sind bei mir im badezimmer
und wir fangen mit der ersten friese
leiste friese und soja und wenn es euch
gefällt dann lasst doch mal nach oben da
wenn euch dieses wie nennt sich das
überhaupt vermisse scheißhaufen euch
dieses schönheit
das habe ich schon wieder etwas anfangen
los so und als erstes muss ich mir meine
haare waschen ich habe seit wochen schon
geduscht aber die müssen halt nach sein
sonst sieht das nicht so geil aus
los so das sieht jetzt wahrscheinlich
ziemlich scheiße aus aber ich muss ja
keiner haben
er zeigt ob eigentlich wenn die
vorderseiten so mehr brauche ich gar
nicht so das hab ich jetzt zwei ihn
handtuch wie komme ich da dran
so leute ich habe jetzt hier ein
handbuch und jetzt machen es aber
trocken
so ist ja eure glückwünsche die
einigermaßen trockene haare und ich
kenne jetzt einfach nach links also ich
hab halt immer so nach links und
manchmal ich weiß wie das kind also ich
habe meine haare manchmal einfach so
also bisschen schöner loch aber wenn
ihnen das sind mache ich einfach jedes
objekt vor hier also wenn die nasse
mache ich einfach sofort hardware so
dass hp jetzt hier können wir uns sehen
so wollte man hier keine schleichwerbung
tobias sei nicht ganz geil so kann ich
euch empfehlen
krieg ich auch gar kein geld führt auf
jeden fall machen wir das so und dann
kämen ihren bisher immer das lasse ich
jetzt trocknen und in fünf minuten zieht
dann meine frisur eigentlich ganz geil
aus okay leute dann würde ich sagen wir
kommen auch direkt zur nächsten frisur
das ist halt die ich eigentlich fast
immer trage beziehungsweise wenn meine
haare geschnitten setzung vielleicht
kurzinformationen das wissen natürlich
auch die meisten von euch hab meine
haare hier so blond gefärbt kennt ihr
vielleicht dieses video und an den
seiten haben jemals einen übergang und
ich mache also zwischen 5 und 8 mm halt
so gar nicht schneiden lasse ich glaub
rat hin zu 5 cm an sein weil ich schon
heftig lange nicht wie beim friseur war
ich würde sagen wie lange machen direkt
weiter los geht's
was ich natürlich meine haare wieder
raus nochmal schnell das müsste reichen
jetzt fahre ich wieder einhalten
das lied jeder ebene da hinten an so
wird jetzt muss natürlich meine haare
werden weil das ist eigentlich nur kurz
führen
und jetzt kommen wir zum alles
entscheidenden schritt zum ganz normalen
benutze ich auch dieses got to be auch
wieder hier 20 euro kommen keinen job
wir nehmen hier raus jetzt war es das
ist kleber kleber oder kleber speaking
wachs so das machen meine hände
zack zack zack und dann gehen wir das
hier vorne rein und es einfach die haare
reihen auch in seiten bisher bis hier
noch schön dass sich das verteilt so und
ich hatte früher wirklich immer das
problem dass zahlen so aus jetzt und ich
finde es scheiße aus und dann habe ich
ein trick gefunden
man muss einfach mit irgendeinem festen
handtuch dadurch gehen und das geld aus
moment so dieses hand rissen mich eher
fester und passt auch ich geh jetzt
einfach mal für durch ja so sieht das
denn aus die eigentlich nicht aber die
sind schon wieder ziemlich lang deswegen
ich muss auf jeden fall zum friseur
ich war so jetzt machen wir die hilfe
ein bisschen jetzt kann man nicht vieles
aus teilen aldi war nach hier vorne
leute das ist ein bisschen scheiße weil
ich hätte die gerade noch anders und
jetzt so kommen bei einer neuen ein
bisschen haschisch und dann musste das
bergwerk sonst kamera noch ist nämlich
auch manchmal das ist so so puder dann
werden die wieder bis entweiche das kann
man ja auch noch mal drauf tranchen
seien alle möglichen und erzählt scheiße
aus alessi kreis aus das ist jetzt
wieder so ein typisches beispiel dafür
dass es scheiße aussieht
jetzt müsste ich eigentlich alles noch
mal von vorne anfangen dazu hab ich kein
bock deswegen leben einfach nochmal
alles
sondern kommt kann ich nämlich kennt ihr
das
ihr habt so er geht zur schule wollt
euch die haare machen und es wird ein
wirtshaus soll jetzt allerdings lasse
naja egal ein bisschen so ist es okay
also eigentlich nicht aber man kann es
ein bisher akzeptieren
normalerweise sieht das etwas hübscher
aus hier noch mal schnell ein foto
vielleicht gleich noch hin
sie hat einfach originell aus wie so ein
struwwelpeter trägt es noch richtig hin
wäre ja oder habt ihr gerade auf dem
foto schon gesehen hab ich da sah es
noch einigermaßen okay aus als würde ich
sagen das war's mit dem video das euch
gefallen hat ist man daumen nach oben da
würd mich sehr freuen
ansonsten sehen wir uns morgen schon
wieder kommt ein kleines video was ja
auf jeden fall durch anschauen solltet
wenn ihr in einer baby und jahres kommt
um keine ahnung 14 15 online hier oben
links geht es da weiter wo es links
keine ahnung im letzten video steckt ist
nimmt uns damals eingeblendet und ja